- What's up, America?
We're here in New York City,
and this nation has got a
major choice on its hands.
Is it gonna be Mountain
Dew Pitch Black,
or is it gonna be
Mountain Dew Baja Blast?
That's right people,
this is Dewcision 2016.
(cheering)
And we don't need polls!
Because we built a
freaking Dewgrocrag.
- Oh my god, I watched
Guts all the time.
- [Voiceover]
Powered by the splat
for fans to cast their vote.
When you bust out a 90s
icon like the Aggro Crag--
- I've been preparing for
this course since 1996.
- Right.
To pit people between
the most beloved
Mountain Dew
flavors of all time,
you better believe DJs are
gonna DJ fight over it.
(record spinning)
You know what I'm gonna do
because I'm from Brooklyn?
I'm gonna make this into a chain
and wear it around my neck.
These are the kinda values
this country was built on.
I've always wanted to
take home a piece of this.
Get your vote on by
tweeting with either
hashtag vote Pitch Black,
or hashtag vote Baja Blast.
I've got on my purple shirt.
I'm doing it for
the mantle, baby!
The radical rock.
(rock music)
Oh, snap, I gotta go!